cette petite commune de 2000 habitants
est située à proximité de la mer pour
qu'elle soit protégée
il faut construire une digue mais
l'administration tarde à donner son feu
vert
contre l'avis de l'état le maire du
village jérémy boisseau entrepris de
réaliser lui-même un rempart en terre
la buse là on avait dit quand on la
faisait passer il faut la refaire passer
ici là j'ai vu qu'on avait une traversée
ici en chemin
jérémy boisseau espère que cette petite
digue permettra de protéger les
habitants de la mer en cas de violente
tempête
n'ayant pas de réelle protection à
offrir à la population
j'estime être
dans le droit pour pouvoir réaliser ces
travaux dans l'urgence donc comme [__]
s'arrête sur cette digue ce qui préserve
toutes tous les espaces qui sont
derrière nous il faut savoir sur ce
territoire
l'eau c'est pas tous les sens tant qu'on
la voit l'eau c'est tous les dix ans
donc ça veut dire que j'ai pu que six
ans devant moi pour réagir et il sait de
quoi il parle il y a quatre ans son
village a vécu un désastre
souvenez vous c'était en 2010 dans la
nuit du 27 février la tempête xynthia
d'une telle force que les vagues
qu'elles provoquent passe au dessus des
digues de protection
poussé par le vent la mer s'engouffre à
l'intérieur des terres et nombre des
centaines de maisons les habitants sont
pris au piège
parmi eux patrick et nelly roberjot perd
2 heures du matin le couple est réveillé
par le bruit de la tempête
en quelques minutes l'eau envahit leur
maison les colonies vous mentez mentez
et à l'air pendant un mois j'ai voulu
aller voir direct porte d'entrée et m'a
dit non non surtout pas et à ce moment
là et c'est là il m'a dit on va sortir
par une fenêtre comme ça et puis là où
c'est toujours un peu alors là il m'a
dit méfie toi des très froide
donc je me suis crispé j'ai fait comme
lui
boyle voilà je sais qui arrivait au
niveau du portillon je me suis dit coûte
que coûte il faut que nos enfants
gardent leurs parents patrick et nelly
sentir sain et sauf mais sur l'ensemble
de la région
une cinquantaine de personnes meurent
noyés dont trois habitants de charron
[Musique]
depuis xynthia
patrick et nelly non plus beaucoup de
voisins
alors là c'était monsieur madame
derrière au fond que je vais partager le
terrain de à partir d'ici jusqu'au port
toutes les maisons a été supprimé au
total près de 180 maisons ont été rasées
à charmes
après la tempête laissant place à
d'immenses terrains vagues
une partie de la commune a été classées
en zones noires où plus personne n'a le
droit d'habiter en créant cette zone
d'exclusion l'état a bien réagi à
l'ouest du village
une digue a même été reconstruite il ya
un an les hauts remparts en terre de 5
mètres de haut en revanche les travaux
de la digue nord eux sont au point mort
depuis quatre ans laissant le village
sans protection
[Musique]
patrick haenni habitent en bordure de la
zone noire au nord de charron et ils
vivent dans l'angoissé d'une nouvelle
tempête
si la deuxième usine pia revenait avec
la même puissance et tous nous on serait
des premiers noyer ça c'est sûr oui je
prendrais butin dans le quartier
personne ne comprend les lenteurs de
l'administration
l'agent n'est pas homogène pour coup
mais ce qui m'agace c'est que cette
digue nord ne ça démarre toujours pas
elle est toujours renvoyée aux calendes
grecques on se fout du monde
on aura le temps que j'ai noyé vous avez
le premier plan qui annule le deuxième
le deuxième qui a merdé folle troisième
à est parti de là ça dure vingt ans un
trophée c'est trop long vous lorsque
vous voulez blagué c'est une catastrophe
mais on est vraiment dans un pays où
l'âge et on se demande si on se fout du
monde
on marche sur la tête t'es sûr il meurt
vous soutenez - il fait quelque chose
un autre homme s'arrachent les cheveux
pour faire avancer ce dossier
mais cette fois dans la légalité c'est
le conseiller général de charente
maritime
lionel quillet l'élu a proposé un tracé
pour la fameuse digue nord
mais l'administration n'a toujours pas
validé son projet voilà donc ça c'est
tout ce qu'on a proposé donc le refus de
validation d'état il est où pour
l'instant qu'il veut pas entendre parler
de dérive qui sont jaunes les blocs là
dessus voilà tous tout ce qui est en
jaune et la digue nord samedi nord voilà
donc charron hélas hélas wendel a donc
l'eau était rentré ici un peu partout
donc nous on est arrivés conseil général
de charente-maritime en forçant la
décision auprès de l'état d'obtenir
l'autorisation faire digue ouest donc on
est protégé à l'ouest sur le problème
c'est que l'état ne veut absolument pas
validé pour l'instant la digue nord car
pas de protection nord et les
protections à l'ouest donc si l'on
arrive elle va rebondir ici comme là les
digues présentes avaient rebondi
et elle va venir bien entendu faire
prendre un risque majeur sur les
populations
l'état veut tout maîtriser veut tout
validé mais ne veut pas faire les
travaux ne veut pas les gérer et ne veut
pas prendre la responsabilité
mais ils veulent contrôler nous on s'est
très surtout l'état impose des
réglementations très strictes en matière
de digues
elles sont d'une complexité à peine
croyable alors ça c'est le tableau
extraordinaire si le meilleur tableau
convenu du a3 ministre j'en suis à même
juin quatre emmy environnement ça c'est
la procédure pour faire une digue
ceux-ci l'année 1 ceci est l'année cinq
ont tous pas bien donc là ya cinq ans 1
2 3 4 5 fu parti dissident les études
qui sont techniques environnementales et
tous les petits segments vous avez là
c'est des allers retours de validation
c'est à chaque fois six mois ou un an de
procédure pour chacune de l'ensemble et
des procédures validé il y en a plus
d'une vingtaine compatibilité des plans
locaux d'urbanisme police de l'eau
archéologie préventive maîtrise foncière
concertation interadministratif
protection de la réserve naturelle
monuments historiques et j'en passe moi
quand on sera là j'aurai 80 disant aimer
charron sera toujours au risque
pourquoi autant de procédures est ce
vraiment justifié je suis allé poser la
question à celle qui est chargé de
piloter le projet pour l'état
la préfète de la région poitou charentes
elisabeth bornes
certains habitants ou ont parfois
l'impression qu'on privilégie la
procédure les
les études environnementales à leur
sécurité c'est pas du tout le cas
aujourd'hui
construire une digue au hasard ça peut
aggraver un risque parce que
en pensant protéger certains habitants
on peut mettre en risque d'autres
habitants les gens peuvent se dire avant
tout était simple on pouvait construire
facilement
bon aujourd'hui on prend en compte des
enjeux qu'on prenait pas en compte par
le passé des enjeux de risque des enjeux
de protection des espèces des enjeux de
sécurité des biens et des personnes
tous ces enjeux demande des mois de
réflexion à l'administration mais
certains sont plutôt farfelues selon
lionel quillet
on est en discussion dans certains
endroits actuellement sur la couleur des
pierres sur la route chemin puisque si
ce sont des arrangements bleus de fortes
densités 7 admis par l'état mais c'est
pas ni par l'environnement qui considère
que cette atteinte au paysage
on discute de la couleur des pierres et
on met des fois trois mois avant la
réponse
il va falloir quoi attendre qu'un
événement et attendre qu'il y ait des
morts ou qui est des blessés pour que
tout le monde se mobilise
c'est pas une réponse la préfète le
reconnaît il est urgent d'accélérer les
procédures
il faut réfléchir vraiment à revoir
notre législation est notre
réglementation sera pas obligé de faire
un enjeu un dossier mais c'est un peu
épuisant pour les gens curieusement il y
un dossier sur lequel l'administration
n'a pas perdu de temps le maire de
charron a reçu un arrêté préfectoral lui
ordonnant de stopper immédiatement les
travaux dès les premiers coups de
pelleteuse le plus fou dans cette
histoire c'est que si la prochaine
tempête fait encore des victimes
c'est lui qui pourraient être poursuivis
en tant que maire je serai condamnée
pour avoir protégé un territoire et non
pour avoir laissé faire les choses et
encore subir une nouvelle catastrophe
sur ce territoire
si vous n'avez rien à vous reprocher à
un moment donné de toute manière les
choses vous seront en tout cas je le
pense vous seront rendus
malgré l'interdiction de la préfecture
le maire a fini par terminé sa digue
cela a coûté près de cent vingt mille
euros à la commune jugée illégale par le
tribunal administratif de poitiers
cette digue pourrait être détruite